so this is a snapshot of the sky at the
moment that you took your first breath
so if someone had walked out of
Hillcrest General Hospital in Queens New
York
December 21st 1969 and looked up at the
sky this is a representation of that yes
so you were born at the very moment if
we have the exact time of birth yes 738
that just changed science but we have
you with Capricorn rising so the rising
sign tells us the motivation for living
your life and its purpose and like how
you go about that what you want to be
known for so a Capricorn rising wants to
be known for its ability to scale any
mountain do you accomplish any task to
look at something practically and be
like how what kind of to-do list
do I need to create in order to
accomplish this thing so it's like
wanting to be known for someone who is
responsible reliable resourceful and
able to get the job done does that
resonate for you I'm going to say yes I
mean I literally look in the camera
because I'm like you're describing blood
but I mean it's also and it's very
different than the other part of your
chart cuz obviously you're not like this
but Capricorn can have a tendency to be
a little bit removed or remote so if
there's ways in which sometimes you come
off as being a little distant and then
all of a sudden incredibly friendly very
social and I don't even might call it
moody people in this room
but maybe you just need some space
because you're sorting things out and
you're planning them and you need to get
down to business
it's serious look if I had to look
inwardly to myself and to knowing who I
am as best as I know myself I would say
what you just described is me accurately
in that one aspect that one that one is
not you're both no the other thing that
was rising up over the horizon the
moment you took your first breath was
mercury
what does mercury do communicates I'm a
blabbermouth that's what people say
about me I'm a blabbermouth producers
know that my co-anchors know that I'm a
black man but now you can
to say I have mercury in the first house
I can't help it and you have a mercury
that astronomically was a very very
bright evening star which the ancients
would have said oh that's a mark of
someone with a very strong intellect and
a very strong mind and in need for
information I would have said to your
parents when you were born look this
little one's gonna we're not gonna need
a lot of books and periodicals magazines
and comics and like I want this little
one to have as much info as they need
because they're gonna be insatiable this
is remarkable and I only say that
because two things one for years the the
knock of being a blabbermouth has been
one that I've like fully come to embrace
but obviously when you're a kid and
growing up and people say those things
to you they can seem sometimes hurtful
and then you say to yourself why am I
like that why can't I stop myself from
being a blabbermouth as you tell me to
shut the hell up glad I wish I would
have said this first but you have the
asteroid s Calathes conjunct your
mercury and that Greek myth is of a
literally a tattle tale right literally
the asteroid that's named after the
Greek god of tattletaling is connected
to your mercury which dispenses
information so what does that mean
you have no choice but to be a
tattletale I'm not a Titan you have you
have no choice but your your thing is to
give out information and to inquire and
to receive and to collect and it is your
identity and right tattle-tale in the
sense of like you when you learn
something you have to share it
not in mom yeah erica is the one who
knocked over that vase so the other way
in which we can see your insatiable
appetite for knowledge is that your moon
is in Gemini Gemini is ruled by mercury
so it's a very curious sign and your
moon is how you do everyday life but
like learning and the mind is where you
go when
the emotional self or the physical self
or any part of that feels a little off
kilter it's very important for you to
have again access to people you can talk
to and it's in your sixth house of work
so would you say but for your job and
for a living that you talk a lot I would
say yes and it's part of the reason why
I was attracted to this profession in
the first place also I'm really good at
Trivial Pursuit I'm and then you've got
the Sun in Sagittarius which is ever
thirsty for the next quest and the next
adventure and the next travel and the
next like philosophy that it can learn
about and the next leg can launch into
space about some interesting topic you
have Sun conjunct Venus which demands
that you're very likable even when I'm
not when you're Capricorn rising is like
I just want to be left alone and so it
can become a kind of impediment
sometimes to being honest about who we
are because we feel this need to be
pleasant and to be somebody who other
people can connect to so then would you
say that those moments where somebody
might perceive me to be moody or quiet
or Edison is the switch can't always be
on because it takes a lot of energy it
might be to on sometimes it might be
hard to balance that because you want
this is too freaking this is way too
freaky because because on one hand
everything that you're saying to me it
sounds like you're describing me right
on the other hand the things that you're
saying are not terrible I haven't gotten
into the challenging part so when you
look at this what is the one thing that
you would say hey Vlad be careful
well you've got both a square from Pluto
to your Sun and Mars to your moon and so
both of those things definitely speaks
to that like heated emotions was there
ever any harm done to the body was there
anything that you had to work through
physically I want to put our little red
flag around like getting heated
emotionally or if that was a factor
your childhood or with a parent and if
that ever you know like impacted you in
physical emotional kind of ways if I say
to you yes that did happen what does
that mean it means that it's part of
your life experience and then I want to
know what meaning you've made of it and
what it's helped you to understand and
how it has shaped you as a human being
and maybe what it's taught you about the
opposite which would be kindness and
compassion and and safety this reading a
lot of it is illuminating because you
are at least the way you're verbalizing
it is a way that I've never actually
verbalized it myself I know some of the
things that you're describing because
they're in here and they're in here but
I'm hearing them from somebody for the
first time right and you don't know me
but then how do I take what you're
describing to affect change in my life I
think when we experience things in ways
that maybe when we're children and we
feel alone in it and then it's laying
there on the page and you can see it and
some stranger can see it then you're
like then I think part of the healing
process is to feel like validated
witnessed and understood in a place and
I don't think healing can happen until
we feel that you're hired